[Music]
in our eye on earth series we can share
a bit of good news in the battle against
climate change
cleaner renewable sources of energy such
as wind and solar are generating more
power in the u.s
than coal that's encouraging because
burning coal produces
planet warming emissions that make sea
levels rise and weather more extreme
cbs news senior environmental
correspondent ben tracy visited a school
district in arkansas
that's turning sun rays into paydays
let's review real quickly jeannie repke
has been a teacher in arkansas
for 24 years why are you a teacher oh my
gosh the students
absolutely completely the students can i
assume you don't do this for the money
if you're in it for the money it's the
wrong profession
you know it's not the right choice rebke
school district in batesville arkansas
prides itself on putting students first
but when it came to paying its teachers
batesville was next to last in this part
of the state
salaries averaged about 45 thousand
dollars
we weren't keeping people because of
that michael hester is batesville's
superintendent
he was losing teachers and having a hard
time getting new ones to move to this
rural arkansas town
of about 10 thousand people people
aren't in this business obviously for
the money but they should not have a vow
to poverty
to teach either thank you jeanne repke
has been working
five nights a week at the local
community center just to make ends meet
but then she started hearing a rumor oh
yeah teachers love to talk
about an unusual solution to
batesville's budget problems
what is that about really what's that
about that would allow this school
district
to truly live up to its name don't sleep
on arkansas
we'll surprise you every time the school
took an unused field outback
and filled it with hundreds of solar
panels
it also put up a new solar canopy
stretching across the entire front of
the high school
in all nearly 1500 panels aimed at
recharging
batesville's budget the batesville is
the pioneers
and they really did pioneer solar in
arkansas
rick vance works for the local energy
company that helped the district save
more than 600
thousand dollars in utility costs they
did it at a time when no one else was
doing it
when now everybody's doing it solar
power costs a lot less than it used to
mainly because it's now cheaper to make
the panels in the past decade
the price of solar has dropped 89
percent
so to both save money and the planet
more than seven thousand schools across
the country are now using solar power
that's up 81 percent in just five years
but as far as anyone can tell batesville
is the only school district
that's turned panels into paychecks
batesville has
reduced the checks they write to
utilities and increase the checks they
write to teachers
with the money it saved and made by
selling electricity back to the grid
batesville has handed out bonuses two
years in a row
boosting every teacher's salary by as
much as fifteen
thousand dollars the district once one
of the worst
is now the best paying in the county are
you getting more resumes these days from
teachers who want to come work here
not only are we getting more resumes
we're getting fewer resignations
that's good jeanne repke has seen her
pay go up by
thousands of dollars enough to dig out
of debt and cut
way back on her hours at the community
center thank you
did you ever in your life imagine you'd
get a raise because of solar panels
no that would not have been one of the
things that i thought but
what a great idea the sun's going to be
shining anyway so why not cash in on
that
and she's grateful her school realizes
that putting students first
starts with their teachers it's good to
know that they
care about us feels really really good
now our teacher jeannie says one of the
best parts about not having to work all
those hours at her second job is she has
more time to help out her students
who are learning from home because of
covid and you know schools across the
country are using their solar panels in
different ways here in washington dc
this school put their solar installation
above their parking lot
anthony you get a little solar shade
here when you park your car all right i
like everything about this story ben
thank you very much
more pay for teachers solar panels and
we like teacher jeannie
we do yeah i wish she was one of my
teachers yeah jump off this put a solar
panel in front of her you'll pick it up
yeah i like her yeah she's great that
was great ben